what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit clip
titled they got repulsed when myron said
it before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos while you're
at it go
so go follow my instagram it is the same
handle as my youtube channel but instead
of an s
at the end it is a z okay
[Music]
okay
ladies i'm gonna make a point it's gonna
offend you
you guys are not gonna like it but i
need you guys to not cut me off when i'm
going to say this and then you guys are
going to
leave it open to however you guys feel
like but i'm going to give you another
perspective okay
so i've been listening very closely to
everything you guys have been saying so
the topic at hand what i'm going to
discuss is
conditional submission i need a man
to re rise to a certain level that i've
picked by the way
to date me to rise to a certain level
for me him to
unlock my femininity right like
so we're playing zelda here so this is
what i'm going to do
let's go into a dream world okay i'll
need you guys to close your eyes and
imagine
all right
[Music]
we're at a nightclub she closed her eyes
yeah i need you guys to really visualize
this okay
like really like think think it over we
go to nightclub right
and i walk up to you i'm your type i'm
good looking right
maybe not at this point you guys
probably are triggered from my opinions
but
you know i might be your type right
there tall wearing whatever you like
whatever
whatever avatar of man that you like
pretend that's me for two seconds right
and you're like damn oh my god girl he's
coming to me oh [ __ ] oh oh oh
i think he's gonna come talk to me holy
[ __ ] he's my type oh girl yeah yeah and
your girls nudging you like yeah he's
coming he's coming he's gonna talk to
you
yeah and you're like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
and then i walk up to you
right i walk up to you and i smile
you're like yes he's gonna he's gonna
ask me
he's gonna ask me for my number i can't
wait i've been like two weeks i can't
wait
and then i go oh my god i love your
shoes oh my god i love your heels
oh my god you look so fantastic
where'd you get those shoes are those
jimmy choos i got them too oh my god i
got a bag that will match perfectly with
that
blah blah blah right this conversation
goes on for a bit
maybe i told you about how i waxed my
nuts maybe i told you about how i'm
spiritual and i do organic healing
maybe i told you i've been a russian
before and i love it right
and then i go ahead and say would you
like to go on a date with me
i'd love to take you out sometime oh my
god you're beautiful
what would be your response we're going
to start with you just give me a yes or
no that is a great analogy
for i've never really thought about like
being feminine
like for the right person um
i just
i don't i don't think i'm naturally
super masculine or feminine
so i don't i don't know i just kind of
try to be myself
would you go out with me i love you
i would like to pick you my fancy nope
okay no we would not be going out
i don't think so no nope nope
that was a great analogy and i never
thought about it from that perspective
but i've never i've never agreed with
the oh i'll only be feminine for the
right man if you're feminine be feminine
like i think girls that say that are
actually just masculine
like i don't think they're capable of
being feminine that man is
gay let's be real
nope no nope
i will say yes okay you will take me out
yep i'll take you out because i didn't
know
i was assuming the whole time you know
it was just you were judging from
your the book okay you know who the
person was you feel me so
i'm gonna give you a chance i'm gonna
take you on we're gonna go be friends
okay
we're gonna be friends okay that's right
but you know it's up for a friend
and not like you want to [ __ ] him yeah
yeah not like that we could be friends
with you no
we're gonna give it a chance yeah okay
so so that's a no no and man
that's a waste of our time to go out
with a girl as a friend uh like real
talk ladies i got to give you guys the
truth
yeah no negative doesn't want your
friend you're basically saying the
the you're basically saying the man was
gay no no he's not gay
as a matter of fact i gotta add on to
the story you guys automatically said no
but what if i say you're like well you
know what i don't want to date you and
i'm saying no
no baby girl don't don't worry about it
i'm masculine when i meet a feminine
woman
are you feminine oh no it sounds
[ __ ] doesn't it
now i'm telling you i'm conditionally
masculine
based on the woman being feminine you
see how astonishing your argument is
here's the problem let me please finish
i even said in the beginning don't cut
me off
this is the world we live in ladies
where a man's roles
are static you are expected to be
masculine at all times
whereas a woman's roles are negotiable
you can be a lady when you [ __ ] feel
like it
and here's the thing you know who loses
you lose
because when you're not naturally
feminine and you have this masculine
energy
let me tell you a son about men that you
guys want they have options
why am i going to deal with this crass
annoying rude obnoxious
masculine woman that's trying to compete
with me when i can go get a naturally
submissive attractive woman
that's going to follow my lead and want
peace
not a competitor or a whole partnership
they want to lead this tweet perry
hilton and i'm actually very happy that
all of you were familiar with this tweet
because it goes to speak volumes about
modern day women today
modern day women today follow women like
this
that don't know what the hell they're
talking about because
her saying i'm conditionally feminine is
like me going up to you wearing a dress
and heel saying i'm conditionally
masculine until i meet a girl
that is feminine that is a [ __ ]
concept but we allow women to walk
around with this backwards
mindset but men are never allowed to
have this right
so by your logic that's exactly what's
going on now
this goes to a deeper rooted problem
that you alluded to earlier
we live in a world now where women are
taught
from a young age that acting like a man
being strong and independent
and having your own and 50 50
partnerships is what men want
it is not what men want and as a matter
of fact the stats back it
we have the highest divorce rates we've
ever had we have the lowest marriage
rates we've ever had
and 80 of divorces are initiated by
women
you also realize that there are also
um 90 of like marriages
are pushed on by women not men yeah like
the women are the ones that exactly
immigrate and then they initiate the
divorce
so who like you notice how when this
girl the less attractive girl cuts him
off
he like yells at her but this girl
it's just funny people treat people so
different based on how they look
so what i'm trying to say is is that we
have
clear cut black and white data
that shows that 50 50 partnerships don't
work we have clear-cut data that is but
you don't know the cause you can't just
say
i'm not arguing that that could
potentially be a cause but like it's
more of a question how do you know
that's the cause
because the number one cause of divorce
has to do with infidelity
so how how is infidelity
a 50 50 partnership as women have become
more liberated and by virtue become more
masculine and become more how do i say
this
independent marriages have suffered as a
result and we have more single women
than ever before
and on top of that we have the lowest
approval ratings of life
from women as women have gotten more
rights they've been less and less happy
one in four women walks around
doped up on uh anti-depression
medication and anxiety medication yeah
so who's really losing
it ain't the men i'll tell you how this
because what's happening is this the men
that the women are fighting for
they see what's going on you know these
chicks are masculine these girls are
ratchet these girls are promiscuous
i ain't wife and none of them i'm gonna
just [ __ ] and be good so as men women
have become more liberated
their approval ratings of life have come
down with it wonderful woman is on
anti-depression medication
and the least happy demographic of human
being in the united states right now
ladies
but with empirical studies is a woman
that's 42 years old
unmarried with no children that is a
byproduct of what happens when you're a
strong independent woman
men aren't going to tolerate your strong
independency they're just not going to
deal with you they're gonna have sex
with you but they ain't gonna take you
seriously
so if you want commitment no i would
agree with that
i would 100 agree with what he's saying
um
i mean not i can't possibly say what the
cause of 50
of marriages ending in divorce divorces
um
but i will say there has to be some data
from
before where like like my
grandpa literally cheated had a whole
mistress on my grandma
and like she was not about to leave um
so i don't know there has to be some
data that people didn't leave
because
because like you know they couldn't
economically
and from a man you need to understand
and know your role
men lead women follow and as a matter of
fact you guys proved my point a couple
of you guys said 50 50 partnerships or i
ran the last relationship
where's the boyfriend now oh [ __ ] look
my mom literally like as a single mom
raised me did everything and like
where she's at now and she's married
a lover a carer and she's like yo like i
said earlier
it's not always what you're taught y'all
like i get it we grow up we're supposed
to be independent women we
we have this [ __ ] like the stigma
like this is what it is this is what
you're supposed to do
no baby girl it's not so quick
just to finish up just to finish up yeah
so all i'm saying is
when i put it on the shoe on the other
foot and i gave you guys
i used your same exact logic i'm going
to be conditionally masculine it sounded
stupid 100
so you can't expect men here's the
difference men are never going to tell
women this because if you say things
like this you get canceled you get
called the massages you
get called the [ __ ] telling the women
so do you see that
stop oh my gosh the pretty girl
interrupts him
he did it again he's like nice she
interrupts him let me [ __ ] fit
i hate people sometimes saying things
like this comes with serious
consequences where you get canceled you
lose your livelihood you get labeled
terrible terms rapey misogynistic
whatever with no proof
so if i got to speak for the tens of
thousands of men out there
that feel this way but can't say it
because if you challenge a woman's
independence it's considered
misogynistic
then so be it i'll say it but what i
will say is the more masculine you are
or the more you adopt this stupid
mindset of conditional femininity
the more men are not going to take you
seriously and go to a girl that will
give them
you mentioned earlier something very
alarming you mentioned i want a guy
to put me in my place and be an alpha
male and damn near shake me
here's my thing and here's the thing i
applaud you for being honest because a
lot of women think that way
but here's the reality why should a man
damn near go to jail to get you in line
why should he do that he shouldn't have
to like why should he have to get to
why is a woman's masculinity here and
he's got to rise to damn near murdering
you
to be able to get you in line he puts
himself in jeopardy
some women end up with like wife be like
guys that
are extremely toxic that's why i think
like some girls
literally like that like they enjoy the
toxic stuff
he puts you in jeopardy and i'll tell
you guys another uncomfortable reality
let's look at the justice system men
serve 66 more time for the same crimes
that women commit
men are far more likely to be arrested
if police show up as a domestic call
abuse
so why are men of value that have
something to lose going to sit there and
try to tame some girl
that's untamable that wants her to wants
him to damn near assaulter
why we're just gonna go with the girl
that gives us peace
100 so with that said ladies it's up to
you what you guys want to do
but this mindset of conditional
femininity
will keep you single for a long period
of time and you're not going to notice
it until it's too
too late in your 30s okay so the problem
is older women
don't warn like young girls about
the mistakes that they made like they
really don't
and you know what drives me crazy is
i have older women in my family and
they're like married and stuff
but even just some like whatever when i
realized
that people that are unhappy want you to
be unhappy with them it was when i was
at a family function and i said i wanted
to lose weight
and they're literally trying to convince
me not to and that i don't need to
i'm like no i went to the doctor i could
lose 20 pounds
not not too much more than that like i'm
not crazy overweight but
20 pounds i'd be healthy and like all
these older women are like telling me
not to
why that's what it is man that's my
point so real quick
ladies question for you do you know what
men really want
and you can't use sex so we'll start
here
i don't know what men really want but
what i can say is
everything you said made complete sense
yeah if you guys want to like
chime in on what i said go ahead yeah
that's fine oh my god you see
you cut her off again in the dynamic
that we're living in
not having to deal with [ __ ] boys meant
us having to deal with all of the things
that we want
oh my god how funny is that
oh that was still a good clip i agree
with some stuff he said i agree with
what he said
about the conditional femininity um
totally agree with him on that
um the only thing i think i disagreed
with is i don't think the 50 50
partnership
is percent of what is causing divorces
today i would
guess that it's more of the development
of birth control um
giving women like more of an opportunity
to be
promiscuous earlier and i think that has
consequences but let me know in the
comments what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell i'll
talk to you guys
next time
[Music]